voici l'un des projets qui s'est
distingué pour le défi technologique
cette année dans les yvelines
ce jardin intégrant un système
d'irrigation autonome est l'oeuvre d'une
classe de cm2 de jouars pontchartrain
on a eu plusieurs essais et voilà en
fait on a dessiné les projets qu'on
devait faire au début
et bah j'ai ramené des plantes
certains autres c'est qu'ils ont ramené
les plantes affronter c'est une classe
qui est qui a accroché à la
problématique qui était soulevée
et puis le centre d'intérêt de fabriquer
que je peux ensemble ça a réuni toute
une classe ça l'intérêt aussi javid la
vie de casque du groupe
la remise des prix avait lieu à la
commanderie des longs cours chaque cycle
devait suivre un cahier des charges
imposé par l'éducation nationale
objectif pour les élèves réinvestir des
savoirs scientifiques et un gros travail
au niveau des enseignants et des élèves
puisqu'on va être sur une démarche
d'investigation c'est à dire essayer de
se documenter de faire des recherches
pour essayer d'élaborer un projet appuyé
de répondre à la question de départ
parce que c'est une question c'est une
problématique sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines près de 1000 élèves
ont participé à ce projet un défi
technologique qui se veut également
pédagogique on prend des exemples très
concrets pour pour aborder cette cette
façon cet état d'esprit de nos jeunes
que l'on qu'on leur transmet avec les
profs éducation nationale dont vous la
sauvez partie
c'est ça la pédagogie d'avenir au total
150 classes des yvelines ont relevé le
défi sur le thème du jardin cette année